Definitely
manipulation and control happening in a lot of those churches.
For sure. I saw an abuse of power a lot.
I've seen a lot of things.
I'll give you an example. I have vivid memory of being at this.
This church we were visiting,
and one of the things they're against is beards.
Men can't wear beards.
I know you believe that. My husband has a beard,
so it's. It's.
It's a whole thing. I would look like a seven year old without a beard.
So they're all just clean shave?
Yes, it's a thing.
So I always say, I guess Jesus wouldn't be allowed in your church,
because, you know, yeah,
Jesus had a beard, so that's a whole different conversation.
But they had this thing against beards.
And there were these two guys
that had been kind of in and out of the church,
and they had beards. From the pulpit,
the pastor at the end of the service,
calls these two guys to the front
and tells them to go shave that rebellion off of their faces.
In front of the entire church.
I remember being absolutely horrified.
You were in the crowd? Yeah,
I was sitting there watching all this up.
And I was friends with these guys.
Like, I knew these guys,
and it never sat right with.
I think even then I was probably 18.
Yeah. I was like,
no.